okay so the penultimate episode of
better call saul has just dropped the
entry teases a lot of things for the
finale and in this breakdown we're gonna
be doing a big recap talking about some
of the details in it and also giving our
theories for where things will head in
episode 13. full spoilers ahead from
this point onwards i want to get
straight into it but make sure you
subscribe so you don't miss our big
video on the finale next week by the way
a huge thank you for clicking this now
let's get into better cool soul
now last week had jimmy being stuck at a
crossroads and after hearing that kim
and asked about him he decided to turn
back around and reach out to her we kind
of had a feeling we'd see the other side
of this conversation and it's something
that this entry heavily focuses on the
episode is very much about kim cutting
off all the ties to the past and
relieving herself of the guilt that
she's been carrying the last couple of
years the first part of severing herself
off from her old version comes early on
when we open with saul in his office
she's here to get through their divorce
papers and this is very much the first
document in the episode that leads to a
big transformation for her we catch saul
throwing a ball of the constitution and
also see his law degree from the
university of american samoa american
samoa isn't a real university and the
name on it saul goodman is of course
also a fake one showing how much of a
facade this entire thing is got a lot of
shining vibes here with him just
bouncing the ball rather than being
productive and he knocks down one of the
columns further showing how fake this
entire thing is soul is in one of his
more garish suits yet and the salmon
blazer striped shirt and tie arguably
shows how hideous of a person that he's
become yes it's a reach but from here on
out we cut to the title sequence
[Music]
again this is heavily shortened down
with us almost instantly skipping to the
blue screen of death that you get when a
vhs tape hits its end point this of
course signifies how the show is coming
to a close but we do get a glimpse of
jeff's cab which becomes a big focus
here and much in the same way that jimmy
has drastically changed every time he's
taken on a new stage in life we see how
this has happened with kim ii she's now
missing the ponytail has dyed her hair
brown and she's also become completely
reserved and putting her opinion forward
she dates a bit a bit of a douche that
wears a shirt with tigers on wrap around
sunglasses and also says yep yep yep
during sex turns out he's just got back
from the shop but rather than bringing
her mayonnaise he's brought her miracle
whip this is symbolic on a number of
levels as it's a fake substitute for the
real thing that doesn't actually do the
job it was intended to much like kim
that's the biggest reach you'll do with
it well it's probably not but the
creative team always select things like
this to hit out what the characters are
really going through kim currently plays
the perfect sap and even though the
miracle whip won't really work she just
goes along with it without protesting
because that's the kind of mind state
she has she's so toned down from what
she used to be that she can't even make
a simple decision on ice cream flavors
so maybe what do you think vanilla
or strawberry
um
they're both good i know right now it
turns out that she does work at the
sprinkler company that victor rang last
week and she's clearly not stimulated by
the life that she now leads she's stuck
in the typical office environment
signing birthday cards for tommy making
felt a coffee and just having
conversations that she already knows the
answer to it's clear she's not really
been able to get back into her groove
and she finally makes a drastic decision
after victor gets in touch now she
instantly knows it's him because of the
name victor sinclair in one of their
scams kim went under the name gisele
sinclair which gives it away right from
the off similar to the shot last week
where we saw things from the outside we
too get that perspective here right at
the beginning now it's a really awkward
conversation in which jimmy gradually
baits her more and more and more
i'm still out here still getting away
with it
feds couldn't find their own ass with
both hands and a proctologist you
shouldn't be calling me oh he very much
has a hubris in this entry that's
ultimately going to lead to him getting
caught kim says he's probably not living
a big life which he also says back to
her both have had a major fall from
grace and jimmy finally pushes her over
the edge when he tells her to hand
herself in she actually does this in the
episode and ultimately both her and
marion are likely gonna be the ones that
end up bringing him down you also have
this moment where jimmy talks about how
all the people that will come after her
are dead
what is stopping you
brings in the ground
mike's in the ground lalo's in the
ground apparently love this line about
lalo as saul of course didn't think that
he was fully dead and he constantly had
ptsd that he was gonna come back she
also ends the call with his
heartbreaking goodbye
kim i'm glad you're alive
i honestly think that if he'd been more
comforting a kind that he could have
talked her out of it but this call very
much lights the match that sparks up the
flame to make her clear her conscience
nice metaphor here of the match used to
spark up the candle on the buff
did say some of the reaches would be
pretty bad now she returns to
albuquerque and then goes to the
courthouse whereas mike once worked the
barrier we see that it's now automated
with a credit card machine she drops off
the confession and also goes to cheryl
where she tells her in black and white
how they destroyed how it's life such
good direction here with the sound being
completely absent while cheryl reads and
we get these long takes over the text as
we see certain segments of exactly what
they did it's all laid out and seeing it
presented like this makes you realize
just how evil jimmy and kim were
they saw it as a big joke but that all
changed with the death of howard akim
says he didn't suffer but it's clear
that he has which cheryl brings up the
reputation they gave to howard has
ruined his legacy but kim's here to
right the wrongs of it however she might
not even get charged as there's no
physical evidence or witnesses except
for you guessed it jimmy mcgill now what
this will lead to we don't fully know
but i think it's clear that kim is going
to ask jimmy to confess once he's
finally locked up with this being a
legal show i think that's the way things
are going to go and sure we could see
him killed or something else but the
more i think about it the more i think
that jail is where this all will head we
are very much dealing with the law and
better call saul and what happens to
those that break it even from season one
chuck tried to hammer home the point
that it was sacred jimmy has overstepped
that and thus there's only one way can
really go unless marion knows some good
websites for hitmen now kim does a
better breakdown than us and after this
we cut across to the other side of the
robbery from last week it's way way
simpler than what we thought it would be
with the police just stopping by to eat
some fish tacos is it fish i'll let you
guys decide now in the house you very
much see how it's not so much about the
crimes for jimmy as it is recapturing
the sense of his own life there's a
reason he chose to target middle-aged
wealthy men and they're obviously
standings for saul that could provide
him with an avenue to the things that he
used to have he makes himself fancy
drinks looks over expensive watches and
it's not so much about taking them as it
is about taking back his whole life he
plays a single piano note to make sure
the guy is fully conked out but
eventually he comes to the longer that
jimmy snips around upon realizing that
he's awake he grabs his dog's earn to
knock him out and its name was rusty
which might be because jeff's rust look
we had a good one with the miracle whip
and it's all been downhill from there
now one thing that does kind of come
back around is that mike last week told
saul not to work with amateurs this was
very much in the case of walter white
which led to the downfall of everything
including gus and saul's empire this is
the same case here with jeff leading to
the downfall of gene he crashes right in
front of the police whilst trying to act
cool which is the smoke that we saw last
week now there's two ways of thinking
over this that i've seen people talking
about something gene told him to do
deliberately so that he could get away
others think it was due to nerves but
let me know exactly what you think in
the comments below either way he's the
scapegoat and jeff ultimately ends up
causing the collapse of everything kirk
back to seoul's office where he and kim
go over the papers so does that thing
you do in primary school when he got an
answer right on the spelling test and it
shows the disrespect he has for what's
actually happening this was of course
murray in the phone call and he just
sits on his phone completely ignoring
the situation kim wants nothing other
than to leave everything behind and she
doesn't even take her share of the money
jimmy is completely cold towards her and
is it just me or can anyone believe that
a show called better called saul that's
about jimmy turning into better call
saul finally saw him become better call
saul i couldn't believe it now we also
see someone you might remember in emilio
this was jesse's original partner in
breaking bad and his cameo was followed
by jesse himself i was furious furious
it was that aaron paul didn't look
exactly how he did 13 years ago and
that's it shows going off i'm not
covering the finale can burn it all down
now obviously yeah the guy's gonna look
older and you kind of have to suspend
your sense of disbelief and just you
know just enjoy what we got instead of
thinking about what we didn't now he has
a cigarette with him and the pair are of
course very much the partners who ended
up being pulled in by the kingpins and
because of this they had major aspects
of their lives ruined of course they're
their own people and are also
responsible for their own actions but
they were very much enabled by those who
led them down the darker path he asks
kim if soul is good and kim says
when i knew him he was
great line of dialogue and in one of our
many parallels we catch gene getting the
bus both he and kim live the high life
and having to ride the bus of course
signifies their fall from grace not
slagging off riding buses yet i couldn't
even drive until i was 29 so i did ride
a lot of them but yeah i think they did
this for a reason back at jeans he pulls
himself a drink and puts his feet up but
this time he doesn't turn on the police
radio showing how relaxed and in control
that he is gene probably knows deep down
that he's going to get caught but he
doesn't really care because he has
nothing to lose he gets a call from jeff
pretending to be his son who tells him
that the guy ended up telling the police
that he's been robbed i don't know how
they could pin this on jeff as he didn't
have any stolen goods on him but either
way it makes jimmy go to marion she
obviously brought up how gf got in
trouble in albuquerque and this too is
brought up again unfortunately jimmy
slips up and brings up albuquerque
himself which triggers marion to
investigate where he comes from and so
on she of course saw them last week and
though jean seemingly smooths it over
she starts to look into him we occur to
jimmy listening to the titus hi by
blondie which is about someone sailing
through reporters but they're still
sticking in there much like how jimmy is
though this song talks about dealing
with difficulty it's really laid back
and relaxing much like how jimmy is
really close to getting caught but he's
extremely relaxed about it now marion
has upgraded from cap videos to
commercials and jimmy opens her laptop
to see his old videos playing we bloody
called it but there's such a good little
artistic thing that they do here whilst
the scene itself isn't black and white
we can see that the commercials are in
color because that relates to his whole
life such a brilliant way to depict him
looking back at his more colorful past
that holds a lot of symbolism to it he's
caught can't talk his way out of it and
if he's willing to lie about nippy and
who knows what depths he won't sink to i
also love how marion has a telephone
wire plugged into the laptop that she
then unplugs and puts into her phone you
kids don't know how lucky you are with
wi-fi we had to do this all the time
back in my day now jean rips this out
the wall and though it seems like he
could be you know
doing it up to strangle her actually
think that he was just doing it to tie
her up however this location is
important as it's the same kitchen where
she joked about him killing her in the
first episode they met in he says i
trusted you and this makes him massively
drop his god marion sounds the alarm and
she says saul goodman is in her kitchen
which makes him flee ending the episode
we then cut to a preview of him in color
beside a destroyed car and over the top
of this we can hear him attempting to
get himself a new identity
[Music]
will it work i doubt it as he sounds
really messed up and this crash doesn't
look like it's gonna have left him in
the best of shapes i think that he'll
probably have been chased by the
authorities will have gone off the road
and now be desperately trying to get a
new identity before time fully runs out
we'll see what happens next week though
and obviously i'd love to hear your
thoughts and theories and where you
think stuff is gonna go comment below
and let me know and just to let you know
we're running a competition right now
giving away three copies of doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness on
the 15th of august all you have to do to
be on the chance of winning is like the
video make sure you subscribe
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the episode
pick the comments at random on the 15th
the winners of the last one are on
screen right now so you know i'm not
lying it's not a soul goodman con and uh
yeah make sure you get involved because
i love you guys forever if you want
something else to watch then check out
our writing of sandman which will be
linked on screen right now that's
another good show that's just dropped on
netflix so definitely go head over there
right after this by the way thanks for
sticking through the video i've been
paul i'll see you next time take care
peace